first just for fun here let's say you
two as in real you you have to rob a
bank you could pick two past co-stars to
be your accomplices who do you pick
that'll give you the best chance of
pulling off the heist I I will do each
yeah two each I would pick uh probably
Rebel Wilson and Zac Efron because
Rebel's super funny so I I would send
her in she would just start singing and
then I'd send in Zac Efron as Zac Efron
and people were like what is Zac Efron
doing here and is that Rebel Wilson
singing and then I just tiptoe around
the side and get that Loop this makes so
much sense if you thought about this
that was like very easy it's all I think
about it's all I can think about oh gosh
um I think I'd have to go with Vin
Diesel for obvious reasons solid choice
because he'd probably like get like a
monster truck or something yeah
just like Trail Blaze through the walls
directly and I wouldn't even need a
second person yeah you just go straight
to the open diesel can count for two
yeah maybe like a vampire because they
might be able to just like appear into
the ball right yeah but are they their
characters
they're co-stars they're like the actors
oh your character your co-stars can't do
everything that they've done in the
films or that's how I thought it was
yeah
I'm gonna ask you to each throw a
co-star under the bus now
that you do not want to win but like you
have to hide this plan from them
you dude
are you not telling Nina who's who's the
co-star that would you know who would
like rat you out screw you over somehow
reveal the plan and mess everything up
I'm just trying to go through like my my
filmography like I've worked with I feel
like it would be one of my workholics
co-stars like Blake Anderson or honors
home because they like we have a podcast
together this is important and uh we
just uh we won't shut up about anything
so I feel like they would totally blow
my spot up okay yeah
they're not they're not to be trusted
those guys who do you trust the least I
really don't know
um
maybe you were in work Alex you could
say Blake and honors no no you're right
now and almost together you could pick
someone from that movie oh yeah yeah uh
maybe taisa taisa she's so honest and so
sweet yeah I feel like yeah she's too
honest yeah she would probably have dare
someone be honest yeah she's one of the
best it's refreshing how honest she is
Adam for you with this movie you
produced it and I also know you were
heavily involved in the development of
the script so it was making me wonder
what is the biggest difference between
day one when you first started picturing
this story and what we now see in the
final film I mean Tyler spindell our
director did a great job uh it was I've
never done like the huge chasing action
set pieces that we wrote so like writing
the like car chase through the cemetery
I was like how is this gonna look is it
gonna look cheesy and cheap it looks so
good it looks so good and we built that
entire Cemetery uh and I did it all I
painted everything there's a whole art
Department they're like no I didn't the
liar uh yeah it was it was it feels on
so much bigger than I ever thought it
would you know you read it on the page
and you're like I hope we can pull this
stuff off and especially it starts off
and you watch the first like 15 or so
minutes and you're like oh this is like
a little rom-com type movie I've seen
these people do these type of movies
before and it's nice but then all of a
sudden it just takes a hard left hand
turn you're like this is a damn action
film all of a sudden so that's that's
what I um
you produce a lot do you have any itch
to direct ah yeah maybe someday I uh I I
see how long those guys have to sit in
an edit Bay and uh it's a lot yes I mean
Nina Nina knows she's directed some
stuff you're you have a lot of producing
credits coming up like you have had and
you have more coming up I guess to lean
into that a little do you remember like
what specific experience sparked that
itch to produce and like what are your
goals as a producer to make sure that
you create the onset environment that
you appreciate as an actor yeah I mean I
I think once I left the Vampire Diaries
I remember you know getting the same
offer over and over again for the same
type of role the same type of genre and
I really wanted to step outside the box
and not get pigeonholed and so I decided
to create my own opportunities and it's
been years and years in the making and
they're finally all starting to slowly
come out which is really exciting and
cool but yeah being on set like
especially when I directed for the first
time that was like you know
the vibe was very important to me and I
definitely wanted everyone to feel like
they were a part of it and had a voice
in the experience and so it made for a
really positive and collaborative set I
think I love hearing about that stuff
veering back towards your specific movie
now you have an exceptional ensemble in
this film can you each name a time when
a co-star was just a scene partner you
needed and helped you access something
in your own character that you never
would have been able to reach without
them I feel like there was a scene with
me and Pierce when we like drive out to
the countryside and then it's me saying
I'm gonna help them get the money to
save Parker uh and we're gonna rob banks
together and I remember just
really feeling like I this has to be
real in the moment and I'm opposite
Pierce Brosnan and then afterwards he
was like that was a really good scene
and I just I floated home I was like you
don't even need to take me home transpo
I'll float home Pierce Bros Brosnan said
I did well I respect that yeah I'll
never look at Shrek the same way again
though yeah no I've ruined it for you
for everyone yeah I had a similar
experience on this film with Pierce as
well actually maybe because we're just
such fans yeah I think we're just like
if there's something nice oh my god
um no uh we haven't seen like a
one-on-one scene I don't even know if I
made the movie did I make the movie nope
really yeah
it sucks I know we need bonus materials
what happens in it and what did he do
for you um there's a scene that's like a
late night scene where I'm smoking a
cigarette I think or we did we shot it
two ways once with a cigarette once with
a vape because we didn't know what would
be okay on Netflix where to cover your
bases there yeah and it was just like an
intimate super sweet father daughter
scene that um afterwards he he was just
like he did kind of the same thing yeah
it's a great team
thanks Pierce is the best man yeah I get
that kind of vibe Yeah you sort of level
up with whoever you're shooting with
like when I'm shooting with Adam like
the stakes are super low yeah
and that's why I'm not bringing you on
the bank heist I'm kidding
um
I got the rap sign but I'll throw in one
quick little thing can you two please
make another horror movie together
they're like what movie am I watching
I'm fine with that I like travel betting
things thank you guys for your time
today congratulations